hi I'm Erik Bosse spider-man far from
homes Minnie Easter eggs left all kinds
of doors open for the future of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe but one door
it seemed to slam shut right in our
faces machine our noses totally look
like this is this movies connection to
the Marvel multiverse one scene early in
the film features Mysterio Quentin back
claiming that the events of the Avengers
infinity war and end game films caused a
tear between dimensions allowing him and
element monsters to spill over from
another ultimate reality into this one
he said that he was from earth 833 and
he claimed that this earth is earth-616
now these numbers are nods to the Marvel
Comics which feature a vast multiverse
of infinite parallel realities earth-616
is considered the main dimension for
most of the Marvel characters whereas
earth 833 is the home of an alternate
British spider-man spider UK Billy
Braddock when a clip of this scene came
out before the film's release it raised
some speculation for the possibility of
a similar multiverse existing in the MCU
and that part from home could launch
space 4 into these alternate versions of
all the Marvel heroes but to no one's
surprise Mysterio is a liar he's not
from another dimension he's from this
one which in the film universe is earth
1 9 9 9 9 9 9 not sure if that was five
I suppose be finite Quentin Beck is just
one of a handful of former Stark
Industries engineers who hate their
former boss and use their tech to stage
illusions to make Mysterio look like the
next Avenger kind of like a supposedly
new kid in school with sick clothes
change actually just a nerd whom no one
notice the previous year and he's trying
to reinvent his look after summer break
in yeah this example is about me in the
tenth grade it might have worked better
without that fishbowl I work since
mysterious backstory of being a soldier
from another dimension was fabricated it
would seem that far from home actually
gave us no new information about any MCU
multiverse but Marvel head Kevin Feige
gave us some little hopes when he was
asked about whether Mysterio lying meant
no multiverse Feige said no it just
means he was full of [ __ ]
I mean in Doctor Strange we hear the
ancient one talk about the multiverse
so we've already established it as the
thing guys Feige is referring to the
first time the term multiverse came up
in the MCU and Doctor Strange when the
ancient one explained too strange the
infinite array of alternate realities
who you
in this vast multiverse mr. strain this
along with the timeline Medlin of
avengers endgame established the
existence of multiple realities in the
MCU some of them cosmic and surreal like
the Dark Dimension quantum realm astral
plane and others mere branch realities
of our normal dimension created by major
changes to the past like infinity stone
displacement so Quentin Beck lying
doesn't change the fact that the
multiverse exists still in the MCU it's
out there it's coming back but why did
Quentin Beck use the multiverse as his
backstory and why did he specifically
cite the numbers 8 3 3 & 6 1 6 if they
supposedly have no meaning this
backstory was conceived where the member
of Quentin Beck's team named kou Terman
played by the actor Nicholas cleaves
Beck shouts out kutiman booth saying the
story you created of a soldier from
another dimension fighting space
monsters and Europe was totally
ridiculous
and apparently exactly the kind of thing
people will believe right now so with
team Mysterio's an extended metaphor for
a filmmaking crew boots is the surrogate
of the screenwriter and the
screenwriters are far from home Chris
McKenna and Eric summers use good to
suspend in for themselves they said that
one of their biggest challenges was
inventing a plausible backstory for
Mysterio that even the most discerning
comic book fan might still buy so they
intentionally filled this narrative with
mr. X specific details like earth-616
center of a t-33 so that nerds might
believe this Mysterio has some alternate
reality friendly Mysterio but stepping
into the world of the movie how does the
character gutes know these details is he
just super imaginative and the random
numbers that he came up with
coincidentally matched the Marvel Comics
of our world am i overthinking a movie
always within the MCU the existence of
the multiverse is at best a fringe
theory among these people when the
ancient one introduced Stephen strange
to the multiverse he initially didn't
believe it and even after the reality
altering events of infinity war an end
game when Beck claims to be from another
dimension
Peter loses his [ __ ] I'm sorry you're
saying there's a multi version
I thought that was just theoretical I
mean that completely changes how we
understand the initial singularity
assisi so why would Deutz base his
fictional Mysterio backstory on this
fringe multiverse theory well it is
possible that gutes could be connected
to the practitioners of the mystic arts
around the world like Stephen strange
Wang Mordo that guy Jonathan Pangborn
perhaps something about multiverse
theory could have shown up on some
convincing reddit post or a mildly
entertaining YouTube video really it
seems as though the events of infinity
war an endgame referred to by the
characters in far from home as the blip
have had a profound impact on the
imagination and belief systems of
society within the MCU Beck said that
this multiverse explanation is
ridiculous but exactly the kind of thing
people will believe right now the MCU
public might not know that the Avengers
use time travel through a quantum tunnel
to bring everyone back there probably
confuses over what happened a portion of
society would probably turn to quantum
physics for an explanation that's right
nerds finally matter only my 10th grade
self could know that and know how to get
a fish bowl on his head fringe theories
like the multiverse especially fueled by
rumors stemming from those with
connections to multiverse travelers
would probably gain momentum and
super-smart false flag conspirators like
gutes
would probably appropriate those
theories to invent a so crazy it might
be true backstory to explain how a
superhero no one has ever met only now
appeared in their world and the fact
that this lie worked tells us that the
characters in the MCU are now so so
susceptible to false narratives Peter
Parker being framed as a villain by Jay
jonah Jameson way harder for him to undo
sowing doubt in confusion that many of
the trusted officials and heroes could
actually be scrol shapeshifter imposters
also potentially a really tricky problem
should Marvel decide to do a Secret
Invasion storyline and this societal
confusion creates a need for some great
explainers figures like Reed Richards in
a Fantastic Four if the Avengers need a
great scientific mind to guide them
through this multiverse of phase war I
can think of no one better
the Society of the MCU is now one that
doesn't know what to believe
so whether the MCU will expand into the
multiverse or expand to alien invasions
or social commentary or all of the above
the most unbelievable narratives from
here forward will reign supreme
comment
with your thoughts and follow me on
Instagram and Twitter and Avis and
subscribe to new rockstars to break down
some theories about everything marvel
thank you for joining me and I'm kidding
I obviously never went to school with a
fishbowl on my head it was more of a
medical brace to keep my skull from
growing too large I don't want to talk
about it
[Music]